[Music]
earlier this week the Trump
administration sued the state of
California for its failure to comply
with federal immigration law so we sent
our own Tommy Lehren out to Los Angeles
to find out what California residents
think this ought to be interesting take
a look do you think that we have an
illegal immigration problem in
California
you're smiling you don't want to answer
that question yeah oh boy you aware that
you're in a sanctuary State no I'm not
but thank you for letting me know what
exactly does that mean that means it's a
sanctuary for illegal immigrants I think
that this is a safe place for a lot of
residents to continue living and I'm
proud of that so if your inner legal
immigrant you can be harbored shielded
until yesterday because the Attorney
General said no more of that California
what do you think well I mean if that's
the way that they're doing it then
they're you know we should embrace it
the governor here is a criminal I mean
that that's a criminal act you're you're
going against the law I think it's great
I think America is firing on immigrants
and it should be that way or onerous on
any America should these people pay
taxes and work as keep American for
ourselves
they shouldn't be shelter I think for me
it's just about the rule of law and it
needs to be respected if you want to
come in this country come in the right
way respect our laws respect our culture
and then I think we welcome everyone I
think there's a right and right and
wrong way to do it I would agree
[Music]
do you think that it would be easier if
we didn't have so many illegal
immigrants already you think that legal
immigrants could get in California I
mean like all of our fruit is picked by
undocumented immigrants I I want to keep
eating avocados I don't know about you
do you like guacamole why do you think
Californians are so open to illegal
immigration the term is illegal
immigrants it's not legal and that's not
what this country stands for I just
think that there are a lot of rules that
aren't easy to navigate and we might as
well not try to punish people because
our system is so difficult the happy
medium would be let people come in but
do it the right way yes there we go what
do you think about a wall well I'll be
wasting money a big giant wall
we'll just have to find a new way to get
over I don't believe a fence is the
answer it's honestly I don't I don't
know what the answer is we got a big
beautiful wall with a door would you
like that wall
no you like that Waldo would she visit
the wall No
[Music]
all right joining us with more is Fox
News contributor Tommy Lehren and
Catalina magazine publisher Kathy aru
you believe in the rule of law
absolutely okay is it illegal to enter
this country I asked you the last time
about the permission of this country
it's illegal right it's illegal don't
make me do this again as I said I think
many people entered legally and given
the circumstance are there people are
laws and don't respect American law
that's what I'm trying to get out of you
this is a simple question well I mean
then it comes to a world should we
really have borders isn't this just one
world one planet should we go back to
John Lennon and not worry about
countries and borders and keeping people
out I mean where I went down to Texas
six hundred forty two thousand world I
mean six hundred and forty two thousand
Texans were victims of crime by illegal
immigrants in a seven-year period you
even care do you care about those Texans
I feel you care about Kate Steinle
family I care do you care about Kate
Steinle family of course and I care
about all the families of the kids who
have died in schools because of our
homegrown cream you're like a little
baby long run-on sentence that says
nothing why are Miller littles are just
as bad I actually have a question of my
own do you lock your doors at home and
your residents do you have a lock on
your door do you use that lock I do yeah
I do you have an alarm and why is that
I mean you lock your door you lock your
door because you want to know who's
coming into your home it's not because
you hate the people outside it's because
you love the people inside well that's
what needs to be done with the United
States of America that's what we have a
border we have a right to know who's
coming into our country and why that's
what keeps us safe well that is why I've
said enough about this issue if law
enforcement in my home and people taking
care of me I know that if something went
wrong while I was in my home they would
take care of it but I don't have a
police officer sleeping over at night so
therefore I lock my doors so in our
country we do have systems in place that
if people commit crimes then they will
be punished we have systems in place it
we don't like our doors it's called the
law we don't know
you hear it's called the law you need to
respect the law that made immigrants to
respect the law we don't hear about
millions of immigrants committing crimes
is we hear about 11 million illegal
immigrants and third and 13.5% of the
crime population comes from the
community of only 3.5% well I mean we're
not from the US government in case
you're interested yeah it's such a small
number that we thirteen we have three
and a half three and a half percent of
the population commits 13.5 percent of
the crime yet millions of immigrants in
this country
pay their taxes and do not commit crime
Tommy I don't know how you do this every
week and talk to people that don't make
sense
I make perfect sense probably behind
enemy lines it's alright we're educating
we're doing our job here in California
educating all right